You know, he's, he's doing a good
job with it, but he also said he's,
he's the highest paid fighter in Beltour.
I mean,
just all kinds of like silly stuff,
you know, it's just like, dude,
is that what he said? No. So he's chill
son in a little bit. He's a dork man.
Just huge door. So he's just like one
of those things where it's like, well,
but when the guy's making his debut and
you are a world champion or a former
world champion at this point, what, what,
what inspires you to
call a guy like that out?
Just because I mean it doesn't it help
him? Yeah, I guess. I guess it does,
but it also, I mean I also woke up to
150 mentions on Twitter, so it's like,
well at least people are talking, you
know, at least people that, you know,
people are talking.
I mean that's the other thing too is,
is always navigating the, the
narrative and talking about, you know,
getting people to talk,
getting people to talk about,
I mean over the last couple months,
the amount of times,
like as soon as could be for the amount
of people that were just talking like,
hey, you're the only guy that
can match Khabib's wrestling.
You're the only guy that
could notify as wrestling.
I mean to get yourself in the
conversation. That's what it all is.
It's all well style's definitely
make fights. And that was what,
what became very interesting,
uh,
after the outlier quantify where
people were looking at. Okay,
what about high level wrestlers who
have more refined striking. Yeah.
And how do they line up?
And Kevin Lee was a big one
that people kept talking about,
but you are a big one that
people kept talking about too.
Cause you were saying that you think you
could beat him 100% and him, you know,
having that fight with, I acquaint to
who he was a prohibitive favorite over,
but it went the full five
rounds. And you know, I Quinta,
although never want around,
showed some chinks in the armor.
So chinks in the armor showed it showed
what happens when Khabib can't take you
down. I mean, it's,
it's tough whenever the one thing that
you've always been used to dominating
with isn't working and then you're stuck,
you're stuck throwing punches and you,
and you're in, you know, you
know, he, he just, he's a,
he's a little bit behind in
the striking aspect. Dude,
I've got a ton of respect for the
Guy Mauler at certain times he looks
unbeatable.
He has looked unbeatable where I've looked
at it and other people have looked at
it and people that have fought him,
that have talked that I've
liked the Barboza fight,
he just fucking mauled Barboza and it's,
and it's just a, it's a battle of wills,
man inside of a cage.
And it's just like we talked about,
I knew I could outpace people.
I knew I could out out cardio,
then I could out tough them.
You know,
certain people get to that breaking
point and they break and they can see it.
They go into their shell and they say,
I did a good job, but this one's on him.
This is his guys who don't have that deep,
deep wrestling background.
And they face a guy who does.
There's moments in the fight where you
see that where you saw that thousand yard
stare and Barboza is ours. We was like
it a slog. Like I can't keep doing this.
He goes into defensive survival mode
and you know when a guy does have a deep
background in wrestling and also can
strike, that's what makes it interesting.
And this is why MMA is such a complex
sport because there's so many variables,
there's so many techniques you can use.
There's so many situations where you
might have an advantage or your opponent
might have an advantage. And it's
just, we live for these matchups,
these stylistic matchups.
So when something like that happens and
a guy like could be B has a fight where
all these questions get presented,
that's where a guy like Michael
Chandler comes into the mix. Yeah. Well,
and I love like, after that fight
too, because I said something,
I posted a video that you see the video
me scrambling with comar really small,
like crazy and it was awesome. And I said,
if, if a, if all he has his wrestling,
how do you beat a man? It can't
be taken down, you know? And,
and I got so many messages from,
you know,
Russian guys that just said it could be
time, could be like, of course, you know,
and it's like, um, yeah, I
mean, it's, uh, it's one of
those things, man, where I mean,
that, that fight with Eddie. I mean, the
fight with could be, that's exciting.
Kumara who has gotta be going
fucking crazy right now,
seeing Colby Covington getting a
shot to the interim title. He's like,
you mother fuckers. Yeah, I
know. Yeah. He's, he wants to
fight that dude. No, I, no,
I wouldn't, I mean, that dude is,
I mean, he is, he's a specimen.
He's got wrestling. He's
got striking. I mean, you,
you watch him spar or you watch him hit
myths or you watch his composure and his
confidence while he's sparring
and do all that kind of stuff.
You'd think he's been striking since he
was 11 years old. He just started after,
after college, you know. Well, he had
his good, tough fight with, uh, with, um,
meek mill. Yeah. He'd mail
Mika whatever, Emil Meek. Um,
but I think that a meal meek is extremely
underrated. Extreme manner. I mean,
he's a fucking tough guy. Very
physically strong. Very, very strong.
I was, I was email me a couple of times.
I was like trying to mimic him. Oh,
are you in training camps? But yeah,
we're at the same time and he needs it.
He's done that.
Him and I train a ton together and it
works out well for me because he's a
bigger guy.
I like to go with a little bit bigger
guys so I can just continue to get
stronger and manipulate bodies that
are bigger than mine, you know? Yeah.
And a lot of people were criticizing
him for not being able to finish meek.
But I'm like, you're, you're crazy. Yeah.
That is a fucking animal. It's, it's,
it's nuts. The amount of people, you know,
armchair quarterbacks that are dead
are literally out there. Think saying,
you should have finished this guy.
We are all professional,
like professional fighters
training day in and day out.
It's not easy to finish a guy sometimes.
I was saying,
you've got to stay the fuck away from
your Twitter mentioning. Yeah. It like,
man Shit. Oh my goodness.
Especially for a guy like you,
if you do have something like
an ankle injury like that,
that one fight and then you got to stay
offline for a few weeks for sure. I mean,
I still get it to this day.
Well, how are you training?
Are you working on your rubber ankles or,
you know,
it's like a couple other
fuckers. They know your soft
spot, man. They start poking.
It's good.